Wow squad building challenges we're
going to get into at the second first of
all welcome to Gareth reader lead
producer on fifa ultimate team hey don't
mate you guys doing oh yeah you know
what I mean that was not even a mode I
knew what woman team needed to show now
I realize that how cool that could be
but before we get into it tell us just a
little bit more about squad building
challenges we've been working on this
for a long time so the the studio in
Vancouver and Bucharest and we've always
known we wanted to put something into
foot that lets you use all that Club
content that I know you guys are getting
a lot of that so we don't want to see
people you know buying packs quick
selling the stuff they don't want we
want everyone to keep all that content
and we built all these new challenges to
put those players in and get some
awesome rewards awesome yeah I did see a
blue purple looking card yes my choice
for you that was a nice-looking card wow
what a place and we can have a play for
Blake a sure you're going to show us how
this feature works okay I'm gonna get
taken through it but I mean yeah
scorpion challenges is something that I
think like you touched on it there it
gives you a chance to use every item in
your club yeah there's no wasted item
anymore this you're going to have a way
to use it in some way exactly and I
think as you'll see when you go through
we've set up so many different kinds of
challenges so stuff with leagues stuff
with more puzzles to try to work through
and then also challenges that are just
you know give us some of your bronze
players some of your silver players some
of your gold players Lord and we'll give
you a little bit extra so we want to we
want to put value and all those
challenges that you're doing nicely
should we have a little bit of a play
sicilian pin I'm right I'm excited
something I'm gonna let Castro drive
here okay nice so we got single player
new mode we got a little fresh look here
okay okay let's pop in there so we got
building challenges let's do
we got okay okay so here's here's kind
of what we're going to start with so you
can see we've got some special gamescom
bronze upgrade gamescom silver upgrade
these are the kind of challenge I was
talking about where you're just going to
put in your extra your extra bronze
content your ex your silver content and
get some cool stuff coming up okay so
this is this is kind of the basics and
there's a little little treat over there
but we're not gonna go there yet I'm not
gonna go there yet where's the Swiss
dispenser challenge it's just a cash
return ticket most in the price did it
okay that's fine that's fine that's
awesome one are we when we pop over to
advance for a second dance okay hyper
patients Ivy League's what is this so
these are kind of the puzzle the puzzle
challenges that I was talking about
before so if you jump into hybrid
nations now again we put just some kind
of special stuff up for games calmness
is not everything that we're going to
launch with but you can see here we're
starting to combine two nations three
nations four nations and you can see
where this can go yeah when you start to
think about chemistry different nations
trying to put all that together it's
going to start to get really challenged
a and now I see the requirements for
example for two nations it's donations
team chemistry 60 minimum overall
ratings 76 so you're really have to
think hard try to meet these
requirements for us and we'll get the
rewards absolutely and if you right
stick over you can see oh so this is
what our rewards are / challenge okay
okay and then if you complete this
entire group yeah there's that meta
reward alright so that's on the screen
before that showed what you get for
completing all this content okay awesome
nice so these are kind of our puzzle
challenges I want I want to show you
guys our lead stuff so wanna get hop
over to leagues other leagues here we go
mls there's that blue card it don't tell
me where they boosted stats what do you
think that's very feel like I let me
wanna said he can have that he stopped
if you can place your time that
essentially is what you're saying
exactly so for the MLS this has all the
clubs in the MLS in it you need to
complete all those challenges put all
those players in there and this is your
moeder awards so jinko the
the top scorer last season in the MLS
yeah we were to give some little special
we got that nice new color item in here
it's a higher right it's a and it's a
higher rating so Herod we've got a lot
of freedom to do some cool stuff with
rewards are you were talking about
trading your players or something like
that yeah and then if you've got a
little kind of prize to show that you've
done it when you go and play people
online they'll see oh you've got that in
one of these yeah very close yeah that's
crazy that's awesome yes that's what I'm
expecting you know throughout the year
you might go play online and see someone
with all these different items with
these new colors that really show that
that person they know phut they know
what they're doing they've got a lot of
content and they know how to put it
together to get these items so awesome
that's cool man so we set up something
special in here for you so let's popping
in MLS you can see there's 19 out of 20
completed right so these are already
completed someone's been busy so I
didn't want to make a boring stream and
have you complete this entire challenge
so I would have pastor what I loved it
we set up we set up everything except
for Toronto FC Toronto that's one that
once I completed 0 in progress it's in
progress so let's have a look at that
let's see what's here he missed me what
you have to do okay well this is
acquirements so team camp if you go here
it 1 100 Toronto FC players exactly 11
Italy players exactly 1 Italy plur
shaving come on Italian what would be
their day it is there did a number of
players in squad 11 okay so how do this
is this is an easy one yeah but we'll
let you do this 1k shouldn't have found
now there's an easy way to do this right
if you hit wife or squad builder I could
just search it up chasing yeah it have I
do it the easy way but i think i'm gonna
go position by position to fill up the
11 players now or obviously going to go
with so obviously if you've got the
Toronto players in your club you're
laughing when it comes to the gym and if
you're not if you don't have enough you
can have to go and sauce it yeah yeah so
that's where you can open packs you go
to the transfer market and find those
specific players that you think you need
now I want to give the lowest rated
players right
the players that aren't going for that
much but we're trading it exactly you're
exchanging all these Toronto players for
that rewards I records yeah I say so if
he puts a higher rate the one in there
when he confirms his squad and submits
it he'll lose the item and so you don't
you want to lose your best players not
accurate so Jovian go that's that
Italian so oh it be checked on the left
right there hey you guys player check
done one down okay so let's use let's
use squad builder to fill this thing out
here yeah squad builder yeah all right
let's go away because I got a special
challenge for you cuz enough challenge
alright alright so let's go with that's
essentially one of the simpler ones it's
just about having players from a club
but they can obviously get really
extreme really advanced yeah and we've
got we've got something special for
Castro we're going to show that's okay
but it's not crazy it's a little bit
harder there it is submit so nice to bid
it let's do it submit why do we got here
can you submit that and then thank okay
ice cream so that's here that's your
reward for Toronto for Toronto ok hello
Oh Spencer what's going on Oh advance
advance from Kuwait oh there are they
serious kreygasm to the check
congratulations so this is now by this
is now my club yep so and good where is
that bad boy you guys better in the back
row doing it first challenge complete
you're on a roll son died right as well
oh man alright so I'm not gonna quit
tell this no no you put that in your
club that's mine and now I want to show
you something special we set up for you
there's more loves me ok let's go over
to gamescom challenges gamescom
challenges again stuff we set up just
four games come just for you guys yeah
cashel challenge oh whoa I like to look
at that guy so Spencer out we should
have said something is all quick as I
there's no Spencer's fine i don't mind
watching ok so this is now another
reward yeah 89 rose yeah
get in that special you better get in
there you better get building you're on
the Quran flock your squad builder ya go
you don't that you don't people watching
this you don't have missed this up cash
is your moment okay so this one low
pressure is a little tougher for
nationalities two leagues three gold
players 6050 we got this there are some
public so I'm guessing that means I'll
what someone has to know in my own
relations your stream followers already
have the salt but I figured it out
already but your mom don't we need you
yeah six players in the squad okay let's
do it you've only got to put the non
padlock ones in there okay Huntelaar Wow
all right we're gonna go with griezmann
no no let's go with Rooney let's go with
rooney if like this one's gonna be good
no no I don't want to give up rooney
he's too high rated but you know what
okay no we want we'll go straight to
struggling Mike you're struggling all
right let's go with Griezmann now I need
a French leave i need a French ya la
liga player
and Spencer well you know one thing
while he's doing this we also have squad
building challenges on the companion app
this year yes you can actually play
across both the companion app and the
console game yeah so it's one to one so
you can start on the companion app you
can finish on the console or vice versa
so you can really take squad building
challenges wherever wherever you want to
go and if you're outside the house and
you complete a squad building challenge
you get home you've got that player for
instance Giovinco to play with exactly
yeah love that ok it's what's happening
near castro I'm gonna go with really I'm
gonna give up my Rudy I'm sorry Rudy I
apologize but you know yeah you're gonna
give up revenue picking right so they're
gonna be gone from your club yeah I know
I know it looks greasy I probably should
but I'm gonna go with Wayne Rooney all
right you'll see why I'm gonna go with
Wayne Rooney I need chemistry here so
let's go BPL from England Premier League
from England and then we're gonna give
noble sorry sorry that's uncalled for
not to have apologized ok ready for the
big game I'll remember that Rodwell ok
low res a player because you go free
English guys already now I need another
league yeah and you can't have how many
nationalities was it to know for for so
this last bit has to be three
nationality yeah the same league right I
think I'm gonna go with la ligue on this
one yeah good shall see how that works
what can I while he's doing this care of
what can people expect as the paper 17
progresses in terms of new challenges
coming up and stuff absolutely so I
can't commit to anything right now we've
got big plans for this throughout the
whole foot season so we definitely have
to stay tuned once we launch to see all
the content and into what we're gonna do
with it right ok but it's gonna be a
fair few for launch as well ready for
people to take on yeah we're gonna have
a whole bunch of challenges at launch oh
these are they already there we fair
that I quick that was good rip there are
checked I did it your ratings high you
can't like it good enough but you don't
it too good because then you're giving
away to get exact play it safe XO hey no
sign of Italy I think I'm gonna trade
Rooney for rice
right it's not that sorry it's a good
trade right it's a good trigger all
right why if you're watching but I and
Noble and no my boy yeah yeah I like me
about here though now I get to yeah so
submit let's put this one in alright
here's to that way would come on oh the
bear Astros channels challenge mom take
a picture did you ever think you see
your name in the game no no no that's
crazy um Royce look at that advance
again gonna be my spot club so very a
sunburst nice you got welcome all car
look at that pace 95 days